bonjour comment ce prestigieux rendez
vous avec mademoiselle adjani civile
bonjour ans mais aussi chanter vous avec
la même boîte ndjeng
[Musique]
oui bonjour bonjour c'est pas bon c'est
florence foresti j'ai rendez vous je
sais où je m'en excuse moi entre bonjour
sur lit le coran
oui non il est déjà réuni sia lisez mais
ça marche toujours pas oui oui
adjani à des j am i jambes
oui je patiente check it was je vais
vous tuer arch dis je c'est sûr
[Musique]
pardon je me suis fais pas tu peux le
temps de déjeuner tu as mangé
oui oui c'est bon tu veux un café je
veux bien enfin si vous avez un tu toi
je leur dis moi qu'est ce que tu voulais
me proposer oui alors en fait je voulais
vous parler de la cérémonie des césar
mais merde y'a plus de dosettes à il
faut que j'appelle ma note pour la
livraison
j'oubliais les reprendre non mais c'est
pas grave moi je je m'en passe un petit
nas le vide
nescafé pardon c'était ailleurs oui
maintenant je les dis à votre collègue
et oui bien sûr je me suis débrancher
rebrancher mais ça change rien je
patiente sûre
donc en fait je voulais savoir si vous
vouliez remettre un prix non mais c'est
pas grave sinon c'est quand cette année
le les césar c'est le 28 février à 28
février non je peux pas je suis en
déplacement je peux pas annulée c'est
c'est trop important
moi je comprends vous êtes au festival
de berlin annoncé en même temps
non pas du tout j'emmène mes neveux
center parks j'aurais trop me
centerparcs bah oui tu sais c'est les
vacances pour la zone alors j'ai réservé
du 22 février au 29 février ou trois
forêts en moselle connaît
or je le connais pas sous la piscine à
boules
il adore de ceux qui n'aiment pas les
piscine à boules eux
oui oui oui pendant 15 secondes
j'essaie compter monsieur bongo
moi je veux bien de brancher encore une
fois si vous voulez mais cette fois je
vous garde en ligne
bon moi je vais peut-être vous laisser
isabelle un liseré ans mais sinon ça
risque de prendre 10 heures merci en
tout cas on va revoir et bonne chance à
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci jasper
je suis con avait menti en pratique je
suis pas devenu fou vous allez arrêter
privé vous allez vous calmer elle est
partie en atterrissant dargaud mais toi
tu camille sée la camisole à tension
je vous dis que les partis mais là je
suis pas fan vous savez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]